[Music]
local news outlets across the country
been reporting on this big day and each
each station has their own unique spin
it's pretty cool it's time for Monday a
day on the retail calendar that can be
enjoyed from a desk or the couch enjoyed
from a desk or a couch enjoyed from on
desk or maybe the counter from a desk or
the couch enjoyed from the desk or the
couch you enjoy from the desk or even
the couch enjoyed from a desk or the
couch from a text or the couch from a
desk for the couch with death score at
couch from a desk for your couch from
the desk or the couch from the desk or
the couch from a desk or the couch from
a desk or a couch from your desk or the
couch for the couch from a desk or couch
from a desk or the couch from a desk or
even the couch from a desk or the couch
joy from a death or a pep from a desk or
the couch for the desk or the couch or
wherever you like as long as you got
Internet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like that last guy decided to freestyle
well I'm gonna go off the rails on this
one